joining us with reaction former Clinton
pollster advisor Mark Penn the author of
The New York Times bestseller Jesus is
risen
David Limbaugh and David has done some
legal work for me in the past by the way
and you've also I've never been the
great Christian that you are you your
books have made me a better person let
me put it that way and very informative
thank you we know what their agenda is
David we see that people are openly
lying I don't see an agenda from the
Democrats at all what are they going to
do to make the country better to help
the people of this country they utterly
have no agenda so they pit Americans
against other Americans black against
whites women against men rich against
poor that's why they're so outraged
about Kanye because he is finally coming
out and straying from the Democrat
plantation and only Democrat only blacks
who support the liberal cause can read
we're where we are to assume think about
what these people on MSNBC were saying
that Kanye can't read because he
supports conservatives so that means
blacks who uh who support policies that
will help them don't read it's just
amazing they have no substitute policies
that will work mark I know you work for
the Clintons but you're also a pollster
the bottom line for me is as an American
I want every American to have the
American dream
nice house safe neighborhood decent car
take their kids to Disney go out to eat
once every week or every other week not
have to worry save a little for their
retirement week that is achievable but
under Barack Obama we went way backwards
Donald Trump's policies are working do
you think this is an opportunity for
Republicans to now bring into the fold
demographic groups that maybe have not
voted Republican in the past well look
as a pollster Donald Trump sits at about
45% approval that's below the 50% that a
president really needs despite the good
economy so there's been a lot of issues
a lot of truth even here than Barack
Obama about the same time in his
presidency that is true that actually he
stabilized his polling but he hasn't
he hasn't gotten above 50 look Democrats
believe in the American dream - you know
what are they offering this election
what are they running on except a Trump
open borders keep Obamacare and take the
crumbs back there's a lot of Democrats
running on health care there's a belief
that the Republicans Obamacare helps
health care that it's sitting out there
and Obamacare has had had a resurgence
from from what it had so look well there
are a couple of people saying some
really bad things and look I don't like
what what Hillary said or what Holder
said because I think that Michelle
Obama's right Democrats have to stay
high and when they don't stay high they
basically give ammunition has been said
to get into people's faces
he once said is that I'm gonna send mr.
Burgess to Fox News and take on Sean
Hannity and tear him up he didn't say
that - well in fact when he was
president he was in fact we moved over
to the center reached out to the other
side vying to find the balance would do
a lot better if they did that today but
we had 13 million more Americans on food
stamps eight million more in poverty he
never reached 3% GDP growth look at
record low unemployment for every
demographic David Limbaugh yeah Obama
did not reach out he said get in the
backseat of the car we don't want you to
do a lot of talking he was the most
divisive so sit in the back he said yeah
and so yeah that well the Democrats do
not with all due respect to Mark who I
do respect a lot I don't think the
Democratic Party does stand for the
American Dream they stand for the
fundamental transformation of the
American Dream the American Founding
principles for actually for socialism
which historically has impoverished and
enslaved people and led to
totalitarianism which is why the left is
totalitarian and its tendencies more and
more it just doesn't work Obama the
Obama care millions lost their plans
that doctors and paying double in some
cases triple by the time it was over but
I still mark I know you're sincere I do
believe that